How cool would it be
if suddenly little lightswould
flow down from the ceiling,
opening and closing, interacting with us
like flowers?
Project"Shylight" became a process of years.
We had to learn to build control boards,
develop programmingsoftware,
make mechanics move in an organic way
with gravity and complex silk patterns.
We had tobecome engineers,
programmers,
seamstresses
and choreographers at the same time.
People responded
to them with wonder
and a smile on their face,
. It's not about that it moves.
It's about how itmoves.
We are designed to be in a constant
and dynamic interaction with our environment.
Ourbody responds automatically
to certain types of movement,
movement we already know from nature.
So why are human-built
environments static?
Nothing moves.
Do we realize thatthis also
stops us from moving?